my name is Gregory Oba and I am John
John and I are together today to watch
the next installment of the Bourne
franchise the Great Wall the great
official trailer number one starry
birthday Great Wall of China yeah really
yeah yeah there's there's some more
there's gonna be a Chinese emperor going
wait a minute
bottomless Gophers the thing that's the
whole reason the wall was built we're
not gonna send anybody out of here is
you gotta keep it out of China I hope
this is actually about the great wall so
that joke kind of works it it you've
seen no no I haven't seen but there is
controversy to the white guy about the
Great Wall okay exactly cool
and
laughing mate I'd love to visit that one
day to Venice not real long
they think Milan Tommy it was the monk
there's a history book it's just a quick
whoa what was that I was born into
battle I still bleed
God this is the first war I see
interesting so that's what really
happened yeah they were trying to keep
out a monster the entire time yeah I
never and I didn't think that a white
man was responsible for helping maintain
the great history of Hong Kong China
whatever Great Wall of China this guy do
a hero or something yeah I had a feeling
this guy did here yeah okay so yeah cuz
I was like watching like this looks like
hero hey how's the funding idea I don't
know the exact story behind it clearly
this is fictional
why isn't that name in the exact we'll
see this movie looks kinda like it wants
to be the last samurai crashed into like
a big action fantasy yeah exactly the
fact that that Jiang EMU is holding this
together is what makes me interested I
don't know man this kind of looks like
they got a hot international director
yeah and they're like you can come do a
movie an American movie for us but you
got a cast Matt Damon in this film about
the history who the Great Wall of China
well see that's what I'm curious about
us and it seems kind of weird to have
these two white guys here like it really
does what are they doing there why has
he the chosen one who has to
you know well I have a feeling that he's
probably gonna be in some way
discriminated from the rest of the other
soldiers because he's white he's like
yeah and then some and the white guy's
gonna be come here still it's like the
creepy with a white dude I'm very
surprised I'm a little awkward and I
have a feeling like that Asian the
female Asian soldier they were focusing
on is probably gonna be like oh she's
the really cool supporting character but
I'm sure there are gonna be a lot of
other cool like you know it seems like
everyone else except the one otherwise I
have casting agent actors and Willem
Dafoe's in this what the [ __ ] I don't I
want to see this movie I'm very curious
cuz I have no idea what they're trying
to pay off here other than you know like
an epic with you know monster movie
grafted onto the side of it and Tony
Gilroy wrote it
what max Brooks is the story and he's
the World War Z guy did you ever like
hear those interviews or reading those
articles about Matt Damon talking [ __ ]
on Tony Gilroy about the Bourne
Ultimatum script know how like Tony
Gilroy like drafted a script and then
Matt Damon was like I just couldn't
believe how horrible yeah I use a pretty
public neighbor he was just like dashing
on Tony Gilroy so it's kind of cool
they're getting along again in some way
you can do that and money can repair a
lot of problems the thing about Tony
Gilroy is like maybe that draft was bad
but I've seen a lot of like pretty well
written Tony like Tony Gilroy doesn't
seem like a slouch of a writers this
trailer is wacky to me but its pedigree
is at least fascinating like it's it's a
Tony Gilroy script and as James you you
move movie I'm curious as to how much of
his clout he'll be able to bring to this
it'll definitely be an American movie I
have a feeling I'm curious as to how
much you know of his vision this is this
looks like Universal trying to
capitalize off of the fact that movies
primarily making money from China neck
and I get that universal vibe of like I
kind of felt like I was watching a movie
that would be on the same side of the
Shelf as like van Helsing and Dracula
untold well the thing about it is right
now is I can feel the marketing schemes
and the planning yes so
that doesn't mean it's an actual
depiction of the film itself for all I
know this could be a great fantasy film
great you know historical fiction movie
and this whole thing about a white guy
being here who could totally work in
this story yeah I don't know what the
content but it seems like right now this
story was created specifically for
marketing purposes yeah yeah yeah
because it starts out being like really
in grim and enticing kind of like the
King Kong trailer doesn't that it
becomes sort of like The Last Samurai
like Matt Damon he's the one that he's
really sacrificing for this bad and then
it becomes like Alice in Wonderland in
like a bunch of other things we're all
though the monster thing was a nice
surprise I was like I wasn't expecting
that to happen see I wish I hadn't heard
that there were that it was a monster
movie oh you heard that yeah I had no
idea because I heard Matt Damon in the
great wall and I was like what is that
about and then someone's like yeah but
it's a monster movie I was like what I
just know how it was gonna come together
and I was dying to be his description a
mystery centered around the construction
of the Great Wall of China
I felt like Tony Gilroy was pitched that
idea and then he found out what a really
good because that sounds like a story
Tony Gilroy could write like an actual
like mystery fiction tale but this
doesn't seem like it's about mystery it
sounds like this is just some untold
battle story do that happen you've got
three guys who've done some cool stuff
because the thing is like a Tony Gore
script off of Max Brooks story is a
weird but interesting idea you know it's
like Tony Gilroy could have written a
version of World War Z and that might've
worked he rents really well characters
he's got awesome dialogue and he is
awesome like mystery a lot of the time
but just look is kind of weird looks it
sounds weird I'll probably give it it
doesn't look like Leonardo DiCaprio
story from the página 1 movie they just
won the Oscar for the revenue from the
revenue yeah or or like a Marvel
character to like it just doesn't look
like Matt Damon I don't like this poster
at all no I think it's very misleading
promoting until you see the trailer
where you're like this isn't it like
some historical mystery fiction story
this is like
Matt Damon taking on dragons or
something show the wall with like a
monster or something I'm really curious
about what they're doing cuz you can't
not know that you're gonna get into some
kind of weirdness with a poster like
that it's called the Great Wall which is
like a phrase synonymous with a Chinese
historical landmark this is just a giant
man name for like an epic action
adventure fantasy to be released in
February it's kind of weird in me yeah
okay at the beginning of the year
they're gonna drop this like epic
historical fiction like if you just want
to go with like cynical speculation this
from here seems like one of those movies
that was a really cool team up when they
thought about it yeah and then just the
further they got into shooting the more
kind of a message meaning like it that's
what I feel like this is gonna become
yeah this was gonna work but then
somewhere along sometimes are wrong oh
yes well thank you guys for notifying me
about the light into the channel you can
subscribe
yes it could be worth my time and
possibly Buddhas John is Jerry worth he
also runs facebook.com slash blue house
social media manager they're promoted by
Gandhi and Great Wall of China movie
that's what they should call this the
Great Wall of China movie I think with
you know the Ben Hur remake and this we
got a lot of great films
Oh Ben Hur though I just saw the trailer
again last night it's a passion for
that's for fans who want a sexy Christ